this movie kind I think really started
in December of 2008 and that's when the
last truck rolled off that plant and you
made a short film about it called the
last truck how did that film lead to
this film and did you think you were
done with the story when you made the
last truck totally done we thought we'd
never go back into that factory that
film is an HBO film came out in 2009 and
we were living our lives but in 2008
2014 the Chairman bought the plant and
in early 2015 we got a call saying you
know what's going on down at the old GM
plant we had read the paper yeah it's
big big news but we weren't thinking we
would make a film we you know GM never
led us into the GM plants we did all
kinds of different things to get cameras
in that plant but we weren't we weren't
sort of gunning to get into this plant
and then the some of the folks who had
wooed through Yahoo come to date and
called us because we know them and I
said you know we started talking
someone's got to document this it's
gonna be big it's gonna be historic how
about you guys and they were the company
the original plan was that the company
would hire us to make like the film
which we don't do the company mean yeah
yeah yeah okay but we so we said you
know we'll we're interested it does
sound really like a big story an
important relevant story but we'll do it
if it's our film if we own it if we have
editorial control you don't give us any
money and yet you give us real access
and the chairman thought about it and
said yes thought about it and said yes
because I think without chairman Chows
participation you have no movie when you
are having conversations with him and
obviously he gives you tremendous access
what were his concerns and did he let
you do what you wanted to do outside of
filming the anti-union meeting the I
mean I think in the early days the the
thought of how this would go was so much
like a smooth Road that it was easy to
say yes it was easy to sort of welcome
us in because it's all this sort of
wonderful frothy kind of cultural
intersections happening
and so in the early day I mean the
chairman was like yeah look this is my
story this is what I'm trying to do and
you know go for it the reality is when
you make a documentary that if you show
up day after day after day and we lived
25 minutes from that plant
we went there hundreds of times we have
1200 hours of footage that this amazing
woman will get to us but we were there
so often that we just became normalized
and as things got hard I mean I'm sure
they talked about should we kick these
filmmakers out but it was never like a
hot topic we were told there was a few
meetings here and there we weren't
allowed to film but plenty of stuff we
were and it just you know the slowly
boiled frog doesn't notice it's boy like
we we were just always there and then so
yeah truly I want to ask what that means
logistically as a producer because as a
documentary you're not only telling a
story but you're casting it with
characters and people and when you're
shooting a lot of footage you're also
trying to figure out who the people are
who gonna help you tell that story and
it obviously takes a while but how does
the film evolve in terms of the people
who are gonna lead us through this tale
and how did you end up settling on the
people that you picked including people
who don't speak English yeah I mean I'm
really that Steve and Julia as the as
the co directors here who had you know
been in the plant some of the people
were in the last truck like Bobby Alan
and so they were they came back for the
second film but you all were in there
day in day out and really you know knew
who was emerging as your main characters
wrong I think it's an incredible
character in the film and Rob hare and
Jill Lamont yeah I mean really I think
you know they emerged over time with you
know filming in their day in day out
Lindsay documentary filmmakers can shoot
300 hours 400 hours this is 1200 hours
shot over what time per year
three years at what point do you come
onto the project and how do you start to
figure out what that story is
because you could make 1,200 different
films there's like 1,200 different ways
I can answer that answer that question
yeah I've never seen so much footage it
was a lot you know it's okay I forgive
you no I think it's I'm really I tend to
be attracted to these types of projects
where a director and in this case
directors are so immersed in this story
so dedicated to following the action on
the ground for years at a time and I
don't know if I'm just a glutton for
punishment or what but like I just like
that kind of filmmaking because it
yields the most incredible scenes and
it's like the the downside is you have
to really wade through all that material
and dig for the stuff that shines and
you know it's a discovery process on any
documentary film as you're working
through all that raw footage and on this
one it was particularly so because a lot
of the footage hadn't been translated
when we started editing and so you know
it was clear what some of the big scenes
were in English but we didn't have I
didn't have like a Chinese co-producer
sitting with me at all times I did
sometimes but there was a lot of sort of
watching the verity material looking at
the body language trying to figure out
if something was happening that seemed
worth getting you know translated and
honestly it was sort of like seems like
there's something funny happening here
or something you know tense happening
here and you can see that even if you
don't speak the language and so it was a
you know I had an enormous
post-production team I did not do this
alone I had incredible assistants
translators co-producers and we just set
up a system in which we kind of
identified what we wanted to have
translated and then we were able to get
that back in caption it and really watch
it you know as a varity scene translated
and that when that happened I think this
story really blew up for all of us we
realized
this was much bigger you know then I
mean you right I mean then we had I mean
we knew it was a big story but when you
get to the translations back it sort of
a on early on Lindsay gave us a
challenge she said like let's what if we
say we're gonna build the architecture
of the film on the Verte scenes because
we had also done a zillion interviews on
camera interviews beautifully lit I
worked my ass off to light these
beautiful frames but you know verite has
a magic to it if it's true and and and
that was a great instinct that you had
because ultimately we had the goods we
had the material in the Verte and and
that's the foundation of the film Chad I
wonder of that same idea transfers to
what you're doing scoring to not make
the obvious more obvious to make sure
that the story tells itself but also how
did you see your role in terms of making
a thematic score to tie all these
stories together well the wonderful
thing is by the time I saw anything
Lindsay had already cut most of it so it
was already in a beautiful state by the
time I was brought on I would say the
primary thing I tried to contribute to
this film was taking the things that the
characters are teaching us especially
Wong he was someone that I was really
drawn to this friendship this is the
furnace worker yeah the friendship
between Wong and Rob is just this
beautiful like brotherly love they have
for each other even though they hardly
understand each other there's something
deeper connecting them and musically I
tried to a lot of the score has duets
there's these two things going on we
have two countries that are coming
together and in the case of Robin Wong
it's just this two friends and so like
the closing sequence it's this big duet
between two two things and they're
harmonizing and trying to add hope to to
what could be a very bleak outlook on
this film but Steve something happens in
the film where they're workers from
American workers who go to China and
their eyes are open for better and for
worse and I'm wondering as a filmmaker
when you
go along with them does it change your
understanding of the movie you're making
and of the dynamic between the two
countries
completely deepened it dramatically for
us what Wang was missing we only knew in
the abstract until we went to China you
know he's here stuck in Ohio and he's
missing his culture his food his family
okay so we all I can say those words but
that they don't have impact when we went
to China it was just this immersion into
this deeply rich beautiful
overwhelmingly alive culture community
world the intensity of it I fell in love
with I mean we didn't and I didn't
anticipate that we were going to go we
were in a third tier what they call a
third tier city it's like the Dayton
Ohio of China it's not like Chicago or
Cleveland or New York or LA it's it's
and yet even in that quote-unquote third
tier city the streets were so vibrant
and the people were so warm and
connected and you I just really felt
like okay this is what he's missing this
is what all these these folks who ended
up in Ohio from China are missing and so
I you know in terms of it I mean one of
the goals with the films are trying to
build empathy for people who maybe don't
talk to each other don't get each other
and going to China deepen that in a huge
way
Steve Julie Lindsay Chad thank you for
bringing us your film